tear gas arcs down onto the protesters
to stop them from getting too close to
the fence this confrontation is played
out throughout the day as it has been
now for many months on the Gaza Israel
border these protests have now been
going on for more than 12 months and
they remain a constant source of
friction with Israel you can see the
border fence behind me now this one is
to commemorate the Nakba
the catastrophe in which hundreds of
thousands of Palestinians were forced or
fled from their homes during the
creation of Israel in 1948 but the human
cost of these demonstrations has been
huge in terms of the number of people
have been killed or injured
Gaza's health ministry claims more than
300 people have been killed and more
than 7,000 have been wounded with live
ammunition
since these protests began the injuries
are life-changing and a Gaza center for
amputees they are overwhelmed 17
year-old Mohammad was shot by an Israeli
sniper last November he's now learning
to walk again
in the area next door
eighteen-year-old abdullah is waiting
for artificial limbs he lost both his
legs when they were shattered by a
bullet
[Music]
what happened against the peaceful
protesters is barbaric he says we didn't
make any danger against the Israeli
Defense Force what they did is a crime
against humanity and there are so many
cases at the clinic that they are
struggling to keep up I'm very sad to
see young people without future as they
say that we lost our future after injury
after amputation we haven't any hope to
live why we will survive the IDF defends
its use of snipers claiming the
demonstrations are instigated by Hamas
which controls the strip and are a cover
for terror attacks and its use of arms
is restrained
there is no doubt though that this
weekly mass of people on the border is a
continuing source of tension it's
already sparked days of war the last saw
rocket fire out of Gaza onto the towns
and cities of southern Israel
and retaliatory airstrikes from Israel's
defense forces and what it claimed were
military targets there is now a
ceasefire in place but it is far from
stable and with these protests set to
continue the UN is warning the next
round of violence may not be far away
Alex Rossi Sky News Gaza